if you're being polyamorous and you have
you're dating multiple people is there
usually a main one for you personally uh
for me personally it kind of yes like
right now I kind of two that aren't like
I see roughly around for me it's kind of
just descriptive like if I just happen
to be seeing you a lot more and I'd been
confide in you more than you like you're
descriptively my primary partner but I
don't usually have rules to protect that
I'm down with rules to protect it if
you're like you're trying to build
something like I'll buy a house together
I'd be like okay we need to like
whatever our relationship is we have to
do the thing we're both paying the rent
for the house or the mortgage or
whatever uh a lot of people do have
primaries so it's very common to have
like X like prescriptive like I'm gonna
get married to you and you're not
allowed to like have anal sex with
anybody else that sort of thing what
about like the transparency and the
communication they have to do yeah you
usually try to be super honest extremely
yeah I mean I've learned over time that
like even if it seems like a very small
thing you talk about the small thing
because often I would just sort of have
like a small Twitch in myself like I
don't know if I like that but okay this
is really minor
um it's probably nothing and I don't if
I talk about it's gonna make it into a
thing and I just don't want to make it
to a thing you know and I would I've
come to realize that it's worth making
into a thing because I can't predict at
the time if like the small feeling I
have is going to grow and then when I
grow it now it's like much more to
difficult to deal with so now it's like
any little bit of jealousy I have
immediately communicated I'm like ah I'm
a little jealous of you right now I
don't hold that in at all I used to be
kind of like back when I first started
being poly I used to try to pretend that
I was not a jealous person and that
backfired quite a lot that's really
interesting so you do still feel
jealousy oh yeah definitely and like
yeah and it's also interesting that you
kind of recommend when there's a little
bit of jealousy like to to to bring that
to the surface yeah just like
excessively communicate even if it feels
stupid like this is I feel like a cliche
I feel like a stupid therapist training
video like I just feel ridiculous
sometimes when I'm saying the things but
it's just it's I've learned over time
it's just important to just say the
things because like you know the
traditional view of jealousy is exactly
like you said if you bring it up to the
surface like it's gonna sound like
you're overreacting to everything
but you're saying like still do it
because you're you're basically your
brain blows stuff out of proportion yeah
and it's good to like
a partner like
like right now who's like dating this
other girl and he like really likes her
and you like went traveling with her and
stuff and I was like I feel jealous
about it and I have to tell him that and
that way he can be with me in it he like
he like holds me when I'm feeling
jealous and it's like a bonding
experience you know but it's important
for me that like he's able to handle it
like I try not to date people who really
freak out when I have negative emotions
because I want to be able to express
that I'm upset by something they're
doing without it being taken as a demand
that they change their behavior right I
mean he has to be able to skillfully
handle the interaction yes cool all
right you're jealous like I'm not gonna
freak out about I'm not going to change
my behavior I'm just gonna be with you
in that we're going to sit in it
together
I mean is some of that just insecurity
that you should also just Comfort like
basically alleviate your insecurity
bring it back to like a rational
objective evaluation right my
relationships I love it when people do
not reassure me I like not being
comforted quite a lot okay and so
usually the people I date don't I'm very
gravitating like it's one of the things
people do to make me fall in love with
them is if I say something really like
terrible and they're just like do not
give me any comfort whatsoever like
that's where my heart gets captured so I
typically am in relationships where I'm
like I mean I'm so jealous and they just
like do not reassure me at all and
that's good because it doesn't give me
an out like I have to deal with it
myself right like that the other woman
is better than me like maybe that is an
actual possible reality which I don't
want to be dealing with my life in a way
where I'm like pretending like I'm only
okay when that reality is not true would
you like them to to uh say that that the
other woman is better than you yeah or
that they if they if they feel that yeah
I mean they should say it in according
to themselves like oh I prefer like I
have a better time with her than I have
with you than I would want to know that
yeah and even though even though that
might be painful to hear yes
that which can be destroyed by the truth
should be
ship what is that that your ego or
something like that my ego so your ego
just generally grows and you like the
destruction of it yeah it's like really
awesome it's not it's like a fun
experience like I've
guys be like well you're not as pretty
as I'd like I'm just like oh you know so
stabbed to the heart and but then also
they give me your number after yeah
foreign